hay dos fases militares muy
diferenciadas en esta invasión rusa en
ucrania la primera fue ese
desplazamiento de tropas desde
bielorrusia al norte de kiev por el este
también misiles en el resto del país
pero el objetivo era tomar kiev lo antes
posible no fue así porque el ejército
ucraniano no es el mismo que el 2014
tampoco el apoyo y las armas que tienen
en estos momentos y porque el norte de
kiev no es una zona de llanuras es una
zona boscosa y lo que se vivió allí en
esas semanas fue una guerra una
auténtica guerra de guerrillas aunque es
verdad que la artillería rusa destrozó
casi por completo butcher ping agosto
mel tras perder esa batalla de 15 de
rusia de juego cientos de civiles
muertos asesinados crímenes de guerra
que ahora mismo están siendo
investigados la segunda etapa militar de
la carga estamos viviendo ahora es un
frente de guerra muy diferenciado son
dos ejércitos cara a cara artillería y
es ahí donde el número de bajas de
militares está aumentando de forma
exponencial nosotras hemos visto
a tan sólo un amor de denny pero
llegaban en menos de 20 minutos 100
cuerpos de militares fallecidos en ese
frente en el donbass donde está ahora
centrada la guerra para tomar todo es el
este y poder conectar con mariupol que
ya está bajo dominio ruso y totalmente
bombardeada y destrozada las
consecuencias de la guerra están en esas
cifras más de 6 millones de refugiados
ucranianos huyendo de la guerra y 8
millones de desplazados en estos tres
meses de invasión rusa